no matter who you are
learning about poetry is a huge source
of power you too can write words that
will set the world on fire
we've braved the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace
and the norms and notions of what just
is
isn't always
just this
[Music]
you're going to learn not only how to be
a great poet but how to be a change
maker
when i was first writing poems what made
them so
special to me was that experience of
having my feelings
articulated and named on the page i
could verbalize what was going on in
here that people didn't know for there
was always light if only we're brave
enough to see it if only we're brave
enough
to be it
you should write at least once every day
you can write gibberish you can draw
scarecrows like you can do whatever just
get your pen moving i'm going to be
sharing ugly drafts of my own poems and
show you what it means to perform in
front of an audience trying to be heard
but these words don't sound right could
i ever be
in the spotlight
when i was little i had a speech
impediment which made it very difficult
for me to speak up for myself a lot of
my first few poems were about what it
was like to be lonely because i might
not look or speak like the students
around me
there's always another story to write
always another verse waiting on the
horizon we all can harness the power of
poetry to become stronger communicators
better leaders and also more
compassionate people
i'm amanda gorman and this is
masterclass
[Music]
i want to be the teacher i never had
[Music]
you